welcome back here are my free guest the
violence
of which you will see a little bit more
at the end of this conversation Joshua
Bell sequin rollout there's a quote of
who Berman which I want to read for you
that after world war one and after
realizing what is happening in Nazi
Germany he right I quote I had to
descend into the further depths of my
soul to find the hidden link between my
impulses towards art and my impulse to
watch politics and then I made a huge
discovery the true artist does not
create art as an end in itself he
creates art art for human beings
humanity is the goal and in the
documentary one people one of the people
said you know now a great musician wants
to become a conductor great musician at
that time wanted to change the world one
is for you yeah how do you respond to
this how do you respond to the huge
symbolic I mean this dish finally became
an icon and it became an icon for for
the whole idea and what kind of moral
political responsibility is related to
heart well this is a interesting
question and it's and it's obviously
it's easy to say yes we should all be
involved in good causes etc but it's a
more complex I think issue when it comes
to art first of all the the quote at the
end that you said at one time now
violence wants to become a conductor and
another end at a previous time they
wanted to change I actually I don't
quite understand that quote because
they're two completely different things
becoming a conductor is enhancing
yourself as a musician and and the other
saving the world is something else and
it's 12 both are things that to put them
parallel like that I think is is I don't
wouldn't subscribe to that so and you
can do both there's no reason is that so
so I don't quite understand that the
other the other thing that Hoover on
talked about as far as politics it's a
difficult question because this
something about I mean the art is some
our transcendent of politics politics
when I think of politics I think of I
think what he did what who boom i did
was more humanitarian and political i
would i would say but I guess my by
association with politics is something
not so positive and I don't I don't like
to associate myself with political
parties and plip politicized thinking I
think the artist so far above that is
something that brings people together
politics puts people in groups and I and
that's something that I don't believe
art is about that I don't think this
it's about the individual and raising
one's self worth and and and gives you
meaning for living in this world it
doesn't talk I don't believe art speaks
about a symphony speaks about about
politics or communities it's about being
a human being I think that's more
important yet at the same time at risk
also this old school and the most
represent of death on is is somebody
like food bangla and it's also in the
documentary that hope among deliberative
refused to play at a billion
philharmonic by foodland although food
bangla also you know had this great
faith in music and you know Beethoven
Bruckner and buchner again so it's you
know it's just the fruit regular issue
is interesting because it's very easy
just to say all he was he was terrible
for not standing up and who berwyn did
and he did not it's also very complex
uber one was in a different position at
furtwängler furtwängler had his
orchestra who we felt loyal to there are
many complex he could have done more I'm
sure but I would hate to jump on the
bandwagon and make him into someone
terrible i just i happen to have been
reading your book recently and it's
funny that i actually bookmarked it and
I didn't intend I didn't know we were
going to talk about this but this
fantastic book if you have a red
nobility of spirit we say fine which I
really really love but it's interesting
there's a quote that you put in here
from Goethe where it says he says
um a good work of art can and will have
moral consequences but to require moral
ends of the artist is to ruin his craft
you put that in the book but also since
we also talking here I think that's the
part of the title of our symposium here
we're talking about what is the title of
it all caps on the power of music zactly
and the Holocaust you see they d after
all the Holocaust was well it at least
one in the 1930s and 1940s was almost
exclusively a German enterprise now with
respect to that the minister of culture
a very able guy very glib Gables decide
that the most German of all arts is
music you see and so most musicians
almost all of them very able musicians
who were part and parcel of the great
orchestras of Germany were fired now
when Germans de cultura Trager as they
were known in the 1930s came into Poland
one of the first decrease which was
issued was that not only were Jews not
allowed to play in the orchestra's but
the Jews were not allowed to play German
music now after all you take the 3 b's
you know Bach Beethoven Brahms I mean
how could you not play them and you see
it really is worth noting that Jews you
know i have here even a quotation from a
great news ecologist in warsaw who wrote
during the occupation that Jews risked
their lives and there is certainly going
to prison at the beginning on the prison
threatened them for playing actually in
these
underground for example concerts what
was the most favorite actually certainly
at that time the Ninth Symphony was more
often played in the ode to joy than any
other single piece of music so you see
it's it's interesting you know how JEWS
those that whom all of this was directed
how they thought about this very subject
interesting because it just shows how
are the music does transcend politics
that if you look at the program the
Israel you know the program was that
first big concert with toscanini and the
Israel Philharmonic they've just fled
Germany and the horror of Nazis you know
what their program was Brahms Symphony
Mendelssohn Midsummer Night's Dream he
was almost entirely German music now
isn't that ink that's fascinating that
they would that they would feel inclined
to play German music after they've just
left this horror and yet they did
because I mean this music it transcends
it's not about being German it's about
being a human it it's it shows the
greatest humanity and in the music and i
think that's that's that's the service
that music really provides besides
standing up in front of Congress it's
it's about it's it's making the audience
feel like fellow human beings making
them know themselves through the music
and therefore I think it makes the world
a much better place again having music
and I think it has an important place in
society it seems to me that you live
almost according to the biblical
commandment psycho remember you also
said it in the documentary for you it is
important to remember why well that is
you know there is a Hebrew there is a
almost a commandment the door of the
door
which roughly says you have to
communicate from your generation to the
next generation the door of the door and
I can only play tell you personally that
to me that is particularly important
because you see the last words that my
brother at the time 18 told me when I
was hiding and when he joined that small
group of partisans again he was the
youngest at 18 and the oldest was 24 and
he came to that place where I was hiding
and he told me always to remember what I
see what is happening here to tell those
goals those who do not know about what
is happening what I saw and well I took
that with me and certainly my family
knows and people who know me know about
what was happening during the war that's
that that obligation which we Jews have
stays with me so the door of the door it
is our commandant and I feel that it's
not only what happened during the war
because you see what happened during the
war to us it's still happening today two
others we also not only have to tell
what happened to us but we have to do
all we can to help those or like Rwanda
for example Rwanda shouldn't have really
allowed to happen the way it happened
the United States and other countries
should have done more but it's not only
the one that what's happened in
Yugoslavia what's happened in in Sudan
these things are still happening was
happening in Syria today you see so I
think it's wrong to be apathetic it's
wrong not to talk about these things and
about and we're trying to do something
about these things Joshua is this do you
consider yourself also part of a larger
tradition and r is something you have to
transmit as to make sure that it will
not be forgotten well certainly I think
that's it's it's important and I
involved myself when I can in the ways
that I can you know I certainly believe
that that remembering is extremely
important i'm not alone in that I think
we all of us here believe that and and
so so whenever I have a chance to be a
part of something I will because I
believe that's important you know you're
faced as an artist it's an interested
because being an artist is quite a in
many ways a very selfish thing because
you have to be looking inside and not
outside you'll be looking at yourself
looking at at at the music and what is
truth what is all these things so in
some ways you could call it selfish and
not not the not a negative way so you
have this you have that but then you
have this you want to do
things outwardly and help as well and as
an artist is one of the nice things
about being an artist performing artists
is that we have great opportunities to
do something to be a part of something
and I get letters almost every day from
some organization all of them are good
all of them are good causes you know for
animals for the environment for the you
know there's there's so many things and
they always need you know someone to
help bring awareness by what i can do is
like I'm not a I'm not a talker I'm a
play I play and I can go and people buy
tickets for four to buy a table at the
event and they raise money and I can
they and so I love to be able to do that
I host in my own home things for the
charities that I believe but I can't do
them all you know that's the problem you
can't do that you have to pick and
choose where you can be of use and use
and still have enough time to
concentrate on your craft in your heart
this is an introduction to the thing
which I can to realize that for many
young people the Holocaust is no longer
part of their consciousness it is it's
really a thing of the past an almost
forgotten past signal how how to respond
to that I mean do we have to respect us
as hey look you know we moved on it's
now safe years later other things
happens and you know we understand this
Minister of Foreign Affairs in Poland or
are there any compelling reasons why we
should not forget well they certainly
are compelling reasons why we should not
forget if only to prevent regrettably
these I mentioned three of them but
there are more than just three mini
Holocaust happening almost all the time
and so certainly we should not forget I
think that you could say education
education education and and you know I
remember when I was in school we still
had certain subjects
which were being taught like history
geography and so on today young kids you
know spent most of their time really not
reading books but actually playing you
know with all of these at least in the
United States but is many computers and
so on and I think maybe that's one of
the reasons why fewer and fewer people
know about important things and are less
concerned about events like like Rwanda
and Syria and so on I would like to
think so I also I worry also frankly
about how many young people and those
who come after even these present young
people will be as interested in serious
music as as they were before as we were
all before and I don't know whether you
whether your experiences i mean Vern
Grassley is similar to mine that I see
for example I know when you are playing
in Czestochowa my family my
grandchildren were with me and I tried
to interest all these other people who
also came there to bring their children
and so on and it was it was really old
and easy to interesting and I'd like to
make a couple of points I can address
that and second first when you talk
about education one thing that education
teaches us soak education when we learn
about the Holocaust is six million Jews
were killed statistics like that doesn't
that doesn't teach a lesson at all you I
move it a film like this where you see a
story personal story does much better it
shows much more powerfully I think human
nature I think we need to remember in
this way by hearing stories and really
understanding it not just a statistic
because I think you start talking about
statistics and comparing whether 3,000
people that that fell in the World Trade
Center is less valuable than 6 million
you know and which lesson is more
important who who has bragging rights
for being suffering the most based on
these numbers the fact is that you have
to look at these people the victims as
individuals as well and not just as as
these groups because you get
desensitized to the number so I think
that's just just one little thought the
other thing I'd like to end maybe it may
be on a more positive note in a way
because i think this question about the
younger generation has been has been
addressed at every single generation
going back thousands probably of years
and and the good old days where you know
it but you could look at just like the
Woody Allen movie the one the Paris
movie I forget he makes the whole joke
about that that every generation you
realize it's the same issues the same
and and they've been talking about
lamenting the the death of the older
audiences this is 50 years ago 100 years
ago you see it so I'm not so pessimistic
I think one of the one of the great
things about growing up and getting
older is that you start taking interest
in things that are more meaningful than
trends is a young person you're
interested in what's trendy and and and
sexy and all that stuff and as you get
older you just become more interested in
in things that are more meaningful
unfortunately takes most people a long
time to read to get to that point but I
think eventually you know I think there
should be more people here in this maybe
you know here today but but I think if
when you do this in 30 years there will
be it'll be you know the younger people
will be grown up and they'll be
replacing the audience here so so you
will be here and so so I is for I can
relate it to music classical music
because we hear it all the time it's
classical music dying is this you know
I'll what I'll look at all the old
people in the audience where's it going
to go if you actually look at classical
music and what we have today the amount
of string court to professional string
quartets that are touring the world if
you look at the amount of professional
orchestras that exist compared to the
so-called heyday of classical music was
the 19th century
all the great music was written there
were very few professional orchestras
period there were a few if any if you go
farther back there really warranted they
weren't really professional orchestras
there we have a much richer cultural
life in classical music now I think than
even in the 19th century where is
supposedly this was the heyday of
classical music so and now we have the
internet where we're streaming concerts
we do have young people because it's a
little bit more trendy but that's fine
we have younger people that are that are
tuning in to the internet broadcasts of
classical music youtube all these things
and I think it's it's not it's not so
dire I think it's icy I don't see it
such a horrible future when it comes to
culture and maybe I'm naive but I'd like
to video first of all I would like to
introduce myself my name is ella
Nicholls i'm president of the dutch
ghost of man of society and what i would
like to ask you speaking about the power
of music how do you relate to the power
of music in the concentration camps you
know of course that ohio's a mother died
at Auschwitz just before the end of the
war but um i would do you explain that
people can survive by the power of music
certainly um there are amazing stories
of music that was written in the
concentration camps and and and and one
of the things one of the aspects of
music the power of music that we haven't
really talked about it is really is yes
it's about showing us the greatness of
being a human being and the great minds
of the composer's but one of the great
things about art and particular music
I'm bias I think it's the most profound
art form but personally is that is the
consolation it does give us you know
when you're in pain when you're in pain
I know this from from from chilled
dealing with children when they have it
when they're sad and they're crying what
they want to hear is not how great life
isn't like you shouldn't be upset life
is great they just want a little bit of
sympathy you know you just say you're
sad I'm so sorry I you know and then it
actually that makes them feel much
better and I've learned that as a parent
as a parent now that not to try to make
them happy and one of the things
accusing sad music it's funny when
people feel sad they often turn on sad
music you think why aren't they putting
on happy music is that they feel
sympathy consolation because they they
they feel like someone else's experience
the person who wrote this music has
experienced this in the profound way and
they're not alone and they're not alone
and I think that's a very powerful
powerful thing sequence well I can only
tell you from personal experience that
every time there was a concert every one
of them illegal in what used to be at
one time movie theaters and sometimes in
synagogues in shut down schools there
was never an empty seat and I can tell
you that for my parents for all those
around me these were very very important
events and even when we when the ghetto
was liquidated and we were in this
forced labor camp that munitions factory
and so on in the barracks you would have
at night you would have three or four
musicians somehow there was a violin
somehow there was I think it was a cello
but I think that it was like handmade
instrument which looked a little like
cello and you had singers and really
these were evenings which everybody
waited for and everybody couldn't get
enough of that music so you see a sight
of from the orchestra's which were
organized you know income he would
house which for example where the
Germans like to listen to that music
some of the greatest singers for example
Joseph fair Schmidt sang in the camps
and actually died in one of these camps
but he was singing also not only for the
Germans he was also singing in Rosenheim
one of the camps so music music was
terribly important
you